hmm yeah you know when welcome to video
hope this works gotta update my xsplit
recording software and somehow that made
the whole starting of the recording
extremely slow okay so playing wgm who
bob and she usually I'll place me
somehow and then losers my score is
pretty good seven point five out of nine
but are usually it doesn't look like
that at all a five oh my goodness Alex a
good line actually 93 i think is right
here and then before i think this is how
it is played
[Music]
yeah black is going for Bishop a
six-play this variation I think somehow
92 is is also on my agenda but not
entirely sure coverings he for him and
then e for maybe next I'll up to e4 d
take see 494 b5 there might be some
before for the exchange on f1 we'll see
what she does night BTW seven looks like
the most obvious choice but black may
also play other things preparing maybe
hook 27 interesting again the North
night of Quincy Quincy to really helps
again efore d take see four nights a
form be five before looks well I might
have some compensation down yeah I
definitely have some compensation but do
I have enough I don't know and she might
play this look these seven stuff yeah
one thing I know I'm taking too long
take it along
of course that that was a an alternative
yeah so
difficult let's go it for him I want to
try to be active here but maybe she just
takes twice on c4 yeah that's really
possible then that makes quite some
sense they're just cake twice on c4
I might get this you for porn Becca girl
even just good night a for him okay so
this isn't so very sunny yeah well maybe
book t1 first taking on the DeForest not
really on she had c3 and if I play they
would have played 94 immediately yeah
here nights five looks like an
interesting that's an annoying thing
here she doesn't want me to take on a
six I think and it's a little bit
uncomfortable him you also cannot take
on c5 after DTX and Knight takes e4
l'exposition really looks wrong so it's
a bit of a yeah between a rock and a
hard place thing doesn't look all that
good I think that b6 was right yeah so
she's trying to take this later take
with the Queen i'm sorry i can't play
Bishop f1 and then take it next yeah
let's play simple chess happy being
happy with the with the bishop pal and
maybe the slightly better structure
you
let's stop that point there's one of the
better games against her at least this
time I'm not getting totally outplayed I
really remember those games then
whenever like that was good and then I
somehow swindled myself out of the games
swing loudly games sounds wrong I mean
yeah I needed to swindle to get out of
the trouble right way to put it ok this
this looks kind of nice maybe c5 now
when I'm not so ready to play d 5 or
well not so radius little bit too nice
I'm not ready at all threatening five
quick doesn't have that many good
squares you know Queen trait is good in
the current situation yes if I am still
I'm not really ready for 45
okay i'm going to get a form that's a
good move threatening to potentially
just take I don't have Bishop e3 allots
bad
time warning ah it's a good move I
cannot take the soup takes to form and
that overlooks stuff whoa okay man will
be tuned and get y'all played again what
the heck and from a very good position
this time from a really good position
this time my afternoon I totally lost
him great place we a lot what yeah yeah
y de sister just very comfortably better
and how did I bundle it up again this is
this is excellent of a wide really
excellent Oh Bishop t 2 wins the Queen
basically that's very stupid yeah she
has no square I mean Queen d2 was so
soon let's have played and ending but
there is no good ending so players the
problem this wins the queen or wins
apiece Yahoo p3 was in better now I
didn't I didn't think concretely enough
this is already annoying really yeah I
overlooked e5 I just thought about root
d aid just didn't think about the file
at all yeah the engine gives some some
line that trade two down to draw it I
didn't look for draws you know what I
was thinking
I'm just better and this is a draw now
my position is to lose is the problem
just far too loose okay when I have
Queen at Bishop b2 and win the key win
win everything but no i think i remember
reason to be happy about all this year i
think i played it okay here white is
definitely more comfortable that's your
4k I could have played that immediately
was a bit better but yeah this is so
fairly nice I don't quite understand why
the engine just gives 0.3 but ok I mean
isn't that just a good position anyway
jam and then I stumbled into this stuff
[Music]
alright night you for as possible
interesting I didn't think about this
but that is probably good enough for a
draw of course yeah I know Walter Bishop
d3 this is really am really ashamed
Bishop teacher was not exactly difficult
is it anyway thanks for watching